hello and welcome to this video playing
quattro princesses let's go leave for
come on wow I've got a very bad score
against the sky I come on let's play the
open why not and minus three against a
rather lower rated player and it's not
great so let's see I'm going for me
somewhat rare Lyonya against them in the
night off ok it's playing this very
quickly so would it seem the idea of all
this is to if possible initiate some
play em on the light square Bishop will
come to d3 and then I'm trying to play
on the Kings side trying to prove that
my bishop is better than his bishop
we'll see if this is indeed a factor you
can maybe play d 3 year in this position
just free up this piece yeah he's doing
that it's probably a good move ok I
think I'll take with the Queen to have
queen bee three
ok
let's see he might be just doubling
that's one way to do it I will see 5 and
so on could be success also still remove
that's not easy to play it was a good
movies d three Pawn sack yeah how to how
to play here c3 looks a lot like it
invites sacrifices so this is not a move
I like to play I want I want the bishop
on d3 just making sure that this is on
its best square and then like weekly one
and so on currently I don't see how he
activates his rook room coming to the B
file would be obviously am rather
uncomfortable
he might still play it like some [ __ ]
see for some moment okay i don't have
rookie one which is a shame let's go for
Queen to b4 and now here text of the
pawn them or f2 hmm i don't yeah look I
have one looks like a really meek move
t2 probably but even Bishop g5 then it's
kind of uncomfortable okay I go for that
yeah I want to try for some color to
play even though it weakens III end
might backfire but I cannot just sit
around all day
okay so this is opened up question is
where to get some real playa maybe h4
yeah I have rook f7 maybe rook f7 king
of seven Bishop g6 check King takes
Queen age three yeah this is actually
looking quite dangerous look at seven
look d3 Queen takes it's also dangerous
okay I'm going for that cause I couldn't
calculate this till the end but it seems
very dangerous rook DC 23 king of seven
days h5 yeah thatthat's it's yeah I
think this must be good for me actually
King takes Bishop g6 also looks
devastating his Queen and rook they are
somewhat off for any defenses does he
have some other movie em that's simply
yeah let's say ignores the Hanging Rock
we're probably not i play rogue f1 on
other moves I think that's it
let's see a defense rookie Thea queen d
3 king of seven h5 takes and then Queen
f7 check that should win now I think
that means check queen and rook are not
some defending yeah rook f1 was my
intention so I think I still want to
play that idea now Quincy a checkbook f7
mate yeah so that I think ur that still
works check check mate check mate yeah
hello I think that these remove was was
okay I mean that was certainly very
valid option to opt to activate this is
bishop this one maybe I should have
taken with the rook that's what the
engine is giving that makes an awful lot
of sense actually to have ruby three
okay three sometimes okay this now we
are the from here I mean he I think he
has some compensation for the pawn but
it's not clear how exactly you should
play it III yeah I wasn't happy about
this but maybe I could have played f4
immediately this is this as an option g6
not sure if this is essential the engine
is giving the MOOC to be aid and handing
a five and gives
like for compensation yeah I'm not
doubting that I think that black
definitely has compensation for the pawn
now let's say a 485 if I'm if you look
at this kind of stuff okay but okay it's
not not so easy for him a 4 i've got
clean before before i can go a four if I
like and I mean this is this is
downright and questionable then with the
bishop coming down you know and now I'm
getting some things done here on the
King side this is probably questionable
as it lets this rook yeah it keeps the
zoo gun protected and also it's not that
yeah serving such a great purpose on c5
yeah no I'm getting I'm getting played
this is this yeah I know h4 look F 7
immediately I don't think it's so
convincing check yeah I'm lacking in the
other position I'm taking on h3 and I'm
immediately threatening things so I
think this is okay and now yeah after
that i'm winning with rook f7 oh yeah
the engine agrees that this wins so look
h3 is ultimately losing the game the
computer wants to do this funky can
actually do this right
yeah the bishop is not exactly great on
b3 looking at this pawn all the time lab
leg should be fine young now i mean i
can i can continue to attack somehow but
i'm lacking I'm looking a punch now I
don't have g6 at least I don't see that
it leads to anything as I cannot capture
due to the pin no engine says this is
still only a slight edge so roughly
equal and after that I'm winning check
ya hear it's a forced made already made
in five ok thanks for watching